can you imagine eating bones for
breakfast it sounds crunchy and pretty
gross but that's exactly what the lammer
guyer eats the lamborgyre is a scavenger
which means it eats the decaying flesh
and bones of dead animals
rotting animal carcasses can be full of
harmful substances including toxins
produced by bacteria
these toxins can cause serious health
issues in humans
however the vultures have evolved an
incredibly acidic digestive system
allowing them to eat diseased carcasses
without becoming sick the lamergyr's
stomach acid is so acidic that it can
digest most bones in about 24 hours
vultures are essential to keeping our
ecosystems and us healthy by getting rid
of harmful substances that could
contaminate soil water or food
carcass cleanup by vultures is something
we call an ecosystem service which is a
way that we humans benefit from
ecosystems there are many different
kinds of ecosystem services which can be
sorted into four categories
first we have provisional ecosystem
services which are the resources that
are provided by nature that we can use
or eat like fruits vegetables and fish
provisional ecosystem services also
include clean drinking water timber oils
some medicines and natural energy
sources
we also have regulating ecosystem
services which are all the processes
that help keep ecosystems healthy and
functional
these include bacteria and invertebrates
decomposing or breaking down waste
bees and hummingbirds pollinating all
kinds of plants and trees and other
plants holding soil together with their
root systems to help with flood control
and to stop soil erosion
and of course regulating ecosystem
services also include our friends the
vultures who help with carcass removal
and disease control
ecosystems wouldn't work without
supporting ecosystem services
these are the underlying natural
processes that are the foundation of
ecosystems and without them we wouldn't
be able to breathe air drink clean water
or grow food
take photosynthesis for example
when plants use sunlight water and
carbon dioxide to make sugars and oxygen
without photosynthesis we wouldn't have
enough oxygen in our atmosphere to
breathe and we wouldn't have all the
foods that we get from plants like
fruits seeds and nuts
other supporting ecosystem services
include the water cycle the nutrient
cycle and even soil formation
and finally we also have cultural
ecosystem services have you ever visited
or seen photos of the grand canyon the
redwoods in california or yellowstone
national park these are incredible
landscapes that provide a lot of meaning
and inspiration to us
think about the art and music that gets
made about different ecosystems maybe
you've heard dolly parton's my tennessee
mountain home she couldn't have written
that song about any other part of the
country
you might have hobbies that you enjoy
doing outside too
for me i love bird watching and learning
about all the different bird species
that i can see where i live and that's a
cultural ecosystem service
plus ecosystems have religious spiritual
and historical value for diverse groups
of people for example american indian
tribes have deep ancestral and spiritual
connections to many north american
ecosystems
so ecosystems also play an important
role in maintaining the richness and
diversity of peoples cultures and
societies of our world
but a loss of biodiversity can make
ecosystems less healthy which makes it
harder for us to get the resources and
ecosystem services we rely on
vultures might be able to eat all kinds
of nasty toxins but they can get sick
and die from human made chemicals
for example diclofenac a common
veterinary drug used to treat cattle
will unfortunately kill vultures if they
eat it from a cow carcass vulture
populations have declined by 95 percent
in parts of the world and that's caused
some pretty big problems in ecosystems
with fewer vultures around to clean up
carcasses diseases can quickly spread
and bacteria from the carcasses can
contaminate surrounding soil and water
in turn people can get very sick when
vultures and other scavengers aren't
around to keep the ecosystem healthy
so the next time you see a vulture
gliding through the sky
take a moment to think about how that
species is helping to keep the ecosystem
clean and healthy for all
through cleaning up carcasses and eating
bones vultures play an important role
conserving the health of our ecosystems
by transforming death and decay into
life